[Música]
bom dia
o meu nome é marcos e eu vim aqui pra
falar como vai ser o transporte na
cidade do futuro
um dia ela estava brincando com o meu
carrinho de controle remoto e eu pensei
é muitas de vocês pessoas têm carros não
têm
mas eles são controlados por controle
remoto ou seja a distância eles voam são
elétricos
acho que não hoje em dia a tecnologia
tenham aumentado muito nesses últimos
anos e nos carros também é mais temos um
problema o trânsito
outra o trânsito ele é um problema pois
ele causa cansaço stress e poluição
essa imagem é uma imagem de nova york e
se você olhar bem perto dá pra ver que é
mais espaços vazios do que os carros e
se todos os carros andarem juntos eles
poderiam andar bem rápido então uma base
nesse carro da mercedes
ele é autônomo e é um pra um protótipo
ainda esse carro é ele é muito útil para
os seres humanos pois ele se comunica
com as pessoas dentro dele e fora ou
seja as pessoas que estão fora
ele vai parar e é para os carros atrás e
já vão fazer esses sinais vermelhos uma
coisa muito interessante que ele faz
também é que ele pára e faz uma faixa de
pedestre projeto uma faixa de pedestre
no chão para o pedestre passar então se
todos os carros andarem juntos autônomos
sim o controle do homem é eles poderiam
andar bem mais rápido assim
você poderia ter além do livro
assistindo um filme e também bater um
papo em que seu carro que nem o carro da
mercedes diantes bom mas eu não tô aqui
pra falar acidez que já foram propostas
eu tô aqui pra falar as minhas ideias
este carro é o caos qualquer cargo
ele é um carro que o motorista está
fazendo qualquer coisa
a não ser dirigir e fui eu que criei
este outro carro o motorista ele não tá
dirigindo e tá comendo ou assistindo tv
e esse carro elétrico
esse tal já não a de lego ele é
desenhado ele chama cápsula é um carro
individual de três rodas e por ele ser
pequeno é a bateria vai ser bem menor é
em relação a ele
ou seja ele poderia ser elétrico mas é
teria que ter várias pessoas ou seja é
mesmo ele sendo individual ele teria que
juntar duplamente com outras pessoas e
um atrás do outro e com as revoluções e
com essas evoluções das tecnologias e
pesquisas é os problemas serão
resolvidos e teremos um não ser
agressivo ao meio ambiente chega mais
rápido e seguro e teremos um trânsito
bem melhor
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]